si así como la semana pasada se
eligieron esos 12 miembros del Jurado en
este proceso hoy hemos escuchado los
argumentos iniciales de ambas partes la
fiscalía ha centrado su primera
intervención en asegurar que Genaro
García Luna era una parte importante del
funcionamiento delictivo que tenía el
cartel de Sinaloa y por su parte los
abogados de García Luna han dicho que no
hay pruebas suficientes que demuestren
que su defendido recibió los sobornos a
García Luna se le acusa de cinco delitos
por haber pertenecido a una empresa
delictiva por haber traficado
introducido millones de kilos de cocaína
en Estados Unidos y también por mentir a
las autoridades en el 2018 para intentar
conseguir la nacionalidad estadounidense
él asegura que es Inocente de todo lo
que se le está acusando pero la fiscalía
tiene hasta 70 testigos en este proceso
para demostrar lo contrario algunos de
ellos son traficantes es traficantes
temidos mexicanos hoy hemos visto al
primero de ellos que ha subido estamos
hablando del extraficante conocido como
El Grande hace referencia a sus dos
metros de altura recordemos que formaba
parte del Clan de los Hermanos Beltrán
Leyva en el 2010 es detenido y pasa a
colaborar con las autoridades justo en
ese momento García Luna ocupa una
posición muy importante en México es el
secretario de seguridad pública Así que
como se pueden imaginar el Grande tenía
mucho que decir hoy y una de las
declaraciones más impactantes ha sido
que él mismo fue testigo de cómo uno de
los Hermanos Beltrán Leyva le entregaba
un fajo de billetes en efectivo a García
Luna por un soborno dice que esto se
hacía de manera repetida y mensual a lo
largo de la semana Seguiremos escuchando
otros testimonios igual de impactantes
importantes para este proceso que se
espera que se alargue por lo menos dos
meses